est ce que je t'ai moins qu
il faut la vérité est ce que tu m'as
manqué alors je retourne voir crs a fait
des choix là et après alors je te dirai
qui tu es ayem tu dis tout était dû à m
ou tu reste pas là parce que franchement
là je veux la vérité tu veux que je
redevienne comment
les gens se posent la question et ayem
pâte a disparu depuis des années tu vis
ou de quoique point de vue physique 32
et les ambitieux alors nos tubes you
batave a appris la nouvelle alors je vis
dans le sud ouais je me suis retiré de
parier je me suis un petit peu usuelle
dans le suisse qui n'avait besoin
d'accord avec m avec mon site d'accord
roland basse et célibataire maintenant
ces débats
c'est une question toute bête mon show
de quoi tu vis à vis du divorce science
me suis isolé et d'ailleurs tu es m'a
conseillé aussi un moment donné m'isoler
et de le prendre